there is a quotation in the book of one
of the Israeli prominent figure dealing
with the Iranian issue when he says in a
classified form in March of 2007 that
his worst nightmare would be an American
president any American president picks
up the phone and call Israeli Prime
Minister whoever he or she is and tell
him mr. or mrs. Prime Minister you want
to attack Iran be my guest
I would give you more support I would
prevent you in sanctions against you
I would even give you an aerial corridor
via Iraq but you're on your own Israel
sees this as the worst case scenario and
we do whatever it can to to try and
avoid it and try to convince the United
States that if needed the United States
would initiate the attack first because
Israel doesn't to be alone and second
and most important because United States
has vast capabilities to to execute such
an attack and Israel has limited
capabilities there the the working group
dealing with attacking Iran is
discussing only a delay of the project
not a destruction because a we know only
what we know and we don't know whether
the the Iranians that have been mastered
of disguise before and here in parts of
their program still don't have any sort
of a hidden path somewhere else not in
the turns on a spy on to the two known
sites be the known sites are partly
underground and in any case heavily
guarded with a surface-to-air
anti-aircraft missiles and see in any
case even if we take all these sites out
we still cannot erase the knowledge
indeed the know-how in the minds of the
of Iranian scientists so they are
talking only about delay Israeli
intelligence sees four different
alternatives for Iranian retaliation the
day after strike the first launch of
going to late late estimations seventy
to ninety surface to serve
she hub long-range ballistic missiles
that can reach Israel this is not
considered as a major threat because
they are equipped only with conventional
warhead and in any case Israel is
covered and supposed to be defended by
anti-missile missile called the arrow so
it's not deem as a great threat of
course it would be agreeing deemed as a
great damage to someone to death
specific someone that the missile fails
on his head but generally speaking this
is not something that Israelis are very
concerned second option for retaliation
would be the bombing of tankers of oil
tankers in the Strait of Hormuz and we
saw something like that happening in the
middle of the eighties this would cause
or might cause a direct confrontation
between the u.s. in Iran further rise to
oil prices and and crisis with world
economy third option the activation of
Hezbollah the Lebanese Shiite militia
against Israeli northern border and we
saw what happened with the gloomy war of
2006 when Hezbollah was able to
completely paralyze life with thousands
and thousands of rockets and Hezbollah
is a she is an Iranian proxies they do
what Iran tells them to do and the
fourth and they even declared that if
Iran is attacked they would immediately
attack Israel as a retaliation and
fourth option which is I think must be
the most boring one is the activation of
sleeper cells that were deployed
throughout the world in the last ten
years by Iran Hezbollah in case needed
to to launch a strike of suicide
terrorism against American and Israeli
targets the book the secret war in Iran
contains many of the cases of these
secret cells one of them I have a cell
that was deployed as late 2006 by Ahmad
muniya in New York collecting
information and intelligence of
potential targets in case needed to
strike after an American and Israeli
attack on your honor